hi hi I'm Christian and I am drunk I'm
George
right now I'm hi hi my name is Ian I
have neither drunk nor stumped hi my
name is Lindsay today I'm gonna be
trying to identify a drunk person a high
person and a sober person hi my name is
YK I can tell if people are stoned for
sure I speak from experience I think I
will do a pretty damn good job I think
I'm going to do well in the game just
because there's not too much of a
difference between if anyone can tell
whether I'm high sober or drunk I have I
have mixed feelings
I feel pretty drunk one please don't
tell me I'm drunk already two drinks
down I hope they won't throw up people
think I'm stoned on a regular basis I
don't know why maybe cuz I'm like yeah
man like let's see what happens
[Music]
fast as you can Betty botter bought
butter but she said butters bitter if it
had to be better it would be batter
bitter so twas Betty booter a lot a bit
of better butter butter butter Betty
botter bought some butter but she said
the butters bitter if I put in my batter
it will make the batter bitter but a bit
of better butter will make my batter
bitter so twas better Betty botter
bought a bit of better butter too
confident could have been handling too
familiar with the source material man 10
years of high school training ten years
of high school training I was four years
no I spent more time in high school so I
repeated each year the ignited two years
extracurricular in summer okay okay no
judgment Betty botter bought some butter
but she said the butters better if I put
in my batter it will make my batter
bitter but a bit of better butter will
make my batter better so it was better
Betty botter bought a bit of better
butter only four years of high school
four years of high school a seed in four
years of high scores so Ian you were a
little slow and Ian might be high okay
Christian yes you mentioned that you had
ten years of high school theatrical
training but also people who were really
good at theater often are really good at
those things so I think you might be
drunk
George is high he's very quiet he's very
composed he might be that way normally
he to take his time when reading and he
did a good job but I could talk he was
fully in it
whenever I'm high I'm when I try to do
something that's really hard I just
fully get in it and I can do it
[Music]
oh okay hey hey right dudes cops over
here
[Music]
he's failing that was terrible you made
it look fancy dude they all made it look
fancy looking good there we go still
better than the other than the others
after this round I just think they're
all drunken yeah I had me too that's
exactly what I think - yeah starting now
[Music]
Wow good job very interesting very
interesting this is I think courses
idealized version of I'm sick no pants
no parents at the time didn't have time
yeah he had time Kristin didn't even
draw yours or nothing and he wasn't
really creative so they would agree
think Christians huh Ian's drawing looks
like somebody I would be afraid to meet
in a dark alley the drawing looks really
freakin stoned
yeah if you look fat stoned it would be
late game over yeah then George George
yes
I love tat that and I'm like I found
Waldo you know you just need a ins hat
and you know the bright colors and weave
it it does alter bald
[Music]
after that last round I think I'm
convinced that George may be high I
still think he is drunk you might face
it I'm thinking I agree a hundred
percent if that's the case maybe he's
laughing because we're wrong maybe he's
just sober you know very funny if you
know it would be hilarious
I thought George's bhai from the
beginning as well he's super chill I
mean he's a good high person yeah you
know yeah he was not very
detail-oriented when it came to that
heel-toe thing like nope yeah if I had
been an officer I would have been like I
know so we think Christian is sober I do
at first I just thought he was you know
just very coordinated and and fast and
theatrical but I think it also has to do
with the fact that he's not on drugs
yeah I think he's on drugs too he's high
on life he's on light yeah I think he's
high in life all right lose together
okay put your hands in we're gonna go
okay y'all are drunk this that's the
twist damn it
he tricked us Trier he tricked us hi oh
we got that
I'm just like I'm happy I was hoping to
get at least one person the perception
of sobriety is very subjective and I
think that just like trying to be
self-contained helps a lot so like if
you're ever I don't know maybe this is
bad advice
[Laughter]
[Music]